are we going to talk about aircraft
performance which is figuring out all of
this stuff if you're an airplane
basically how much runway you're going
to use on both ends how long it's going
to take you to get there which is
another way of saying how much fuel
you're going to use if it's a helicopter
it's a little bit different mostly
you're worried about hover performance
so if you're going to a friend's house
are you going to be able to park the
helicopter in midair that's called an
out of ground effect hover and very
slowly descend into the backyard dodging
the trees and powerlines and anything
else so these are all things that can be
found in the aircraft manuals and the
FAA will test you on them a little bit
this is important partly because you
want to be able to complete your flight
safely and also because of our 91 103
which is that before you do a flight
you've got to become a it's pretty
all-embracing all available information
concerning weather and aircraft
performance how the aircraft's going to
perform given the altitude of where
you're going and the temperature that's
prevailing there at the time wind also
you know if you find out that there's a
40 knot wind scheduled for where you're
going and it's a direct crosswind to the
only runway then that might cause you to
choose a different airport okay here's a
reminder of thrust and drag whenever
you're generating lift you're also
generating some drag and that's lift in
the unwanted direction of backwards
usually so the aircraft is also
producing parasitic drag by trying to
punch its way through this viscous fluid
of air
where these sums up drag curves
intersect is pretty much the bottom of
the total drag curve the minimum drag or
L over D max the climb performance the
best speeds to go are all kind of tied
into this drag curve and the best angle
of climb is what you use that's a slower
airspeed and the best rate of climb if
you're in a small airport trying to
clear the trees at the end of the runway
you're gonna fly the X the best angle of
climb this is one of the few V speeds
that you're actually expected to know
the abbreviation for and if you're going
to just take off out of a big airport
like Hanscom field and just want to get
up to your cruising altitude reasonably
quickly then you
hey thanks Richard Richard's a Moony
pilot made it to California many times
[Music]
so if you actually look at the VX one
thing to notice is that it'll depend a
bit on the wind let's say there's a
hundred knot wind blowing down the
runway you don't need to fly very fast
in order to clear the trees at the end
of the runway because you're basically
already flying and you can go straight
up like a helicopter in terms of your
path over the ground whereas vui just to
gain altitude that doesn't depend at all
on the prevailing wind so if you're
trying to clear something on the ground
the wind matter so tailwind would be
very destructive they'll be pushing you
towards the obstacle and a headwind will
be very helpful
crews climb most of the time you don't
actually push the airplane to these
speeds they're pretty far nose up which
is a little bit alarming to passengers
and it's harder to see over the nose and
the engine isn't getting as much cooling
here at these lower speeds so typically
we'll fly about ten knots faster in a ga
airplane so from the cirrus for example
ninety six is the book VII at sea level
and applying something like 105 knots is
more conventional the pc-12 climbs you
know might be able to do three thousand
feet a minute at 120 knots but if you're
not in a desperate hurry to get up above
the bumpy clouds or something then 150
knots is more conventional okay so let's
remember that you've got thrust and
power so the thrust is you know a force
that lets you climb up over the trees
the power is thrust times the speed and
its thrust
operating over a period of time so the
more excess power you have the higher
the rate at which you can climb anyway
we'll see some more of that here you've
got best glide ratio if you want to get
to the decent place to land and you've
lost your engine what's a good speed to
fly well L over D max is an excellent
speed to fly because that's where the
lift over drag is that a is at its
highest point and you'll make the best
time over the ground again that has to
be adjusted a little bit for wind if
you're going into a hundred knot wind
and the Cirrus best glide speed is 96
knots that's not going to work out very
well you're not going to go anywhere
over the ground that's a photo that I
took at the Newport Jazz Festival I
don't want to say self portrait anyway
wait has a huge factor on all these
speeds because actually a lot of them
are related to angle of attack and it
certainly affects your performance so
everything about higher weight is pretty
bad wind you might think that a tailwind
is always good but really the tailwind
is only good for extending your cruise
range everything else pretty much the
headwind is better for so they think
about the headwind again and think of
these extreme cases if you've got a
hundred knot wind right in your face
then you can fly without moving that's
basically a wind tunnel okay senator of
gravity this is also a little bit
counterintuitive if you load the
airplane up so that all the weights at
the back and it's you know super nose up
and you're having to push the stick
forward to keep the plane level that
actually is where you get your maximum
performance everything is better about
having a nap center of gravity with one
exception which is the stability of the
handling of the aircraft and obviously
if you load it up so much in the back
that you can't push the nose over that
would be outside of the CG range or well
outside of the CG range let's hope then
you know you wouldn't even be able to
control the aircraft because you can't
get the nose down enough so having that
forward CG gives you more stability
that's where you're going to be when
you're a student pilot if you're in a
four-seat aircraft and it's just you and
the instructor in front and the back
seats are empty then it's pretty obvious
that that's going to be a somewhat
forward CG because the aircraft is
designed to hold you know at least some
weight in the back seats one thing you
can do is sort of just as a first
approximation you know pay attention
you're gonna have we're gonna have a
talk on weight and balance later from
Tina but just keep in mind that the
aircraft is kind of designed for you
know two adults in the front and maybe
one adult in the back or two kids in the
back so if you load it up that way it's
almost always going to work if on the
other hand you have you know a big heavy
friend and you know his other big heavy
friend or his you know box of anvils and
the guy says look I just want to sleep
in the back you know I don't want to be
up front and get distracted and you're
all and you're a lightweight person all
by yourself in the front you know that's
the situation where you know it's
important to really do the calculations
and think carefully about it because
that wasn't something that Cessna and
Piper we're thinking about when they
designed the aircraft okay
atmospheric pressure a simple remember
we talked about how the atmosphere is
going to be expanded when it's hot and
contracted when it's cold and the
altimeter is really telling you how much
of the atmosphere you've climbed up
through so you can see here on the right
if you look over here you're and you're
measuring your altitude you're basically
getting this whole stack of molecules
contributing to the pressure whereas if
you're up high in the stratosphere or
something only a handful of molecules
are on top of you putting pressure into
your altimeter okay
here's that standard atmosphere again so
you can see it's $2.99 or two and 15
degrees at sea level so the aircraft
performance is hugely affected by
changes in air density which themselves
are affected by the prevailing pressure
which is you know mostly a function of
altitude the temperature and the
humidity usually the conditions are
referenced to the eisah the standard
atmosphere if it's the summertime it'll
be you know I so plus 15 or I said plus
20 and if it's the wintertime it might
be you know ISO or right at minus 20
when the air density is reduced and
there are fewer molecules around the
engine is not taking in as much air for
combustion remember that the jet engines
are normally aspirated and the piston
engines also that are without a
turbocharger they're just trying to burn
up a fixed volume of air and that's
going to correspond to a different
number of molecules of air and fuel
depending on the altitude the only good
thing about going up high the propeller
is also not grabbing as much air for
thrust the only thing good about going
up high is that drag is reduced and
that's why you see the airliners up high
they go faster and they save a lot of
fuel okay some definitions the pressure
altitude is just the it's going to be
your height above sea level with the
altimeter set to two nine or nine or two
you just have to take
the $2.99 or two minus the actual
altimeter setting that's being published
multiply that by a thousand so a full a
full inch of altimeter adjustment like
from to nine or nine or two to three
zero nine or two would correspond to a
thousand foot difference in pressure
altitude and you can calculate that by a
chart here's a chart that they give you
if you don't like the formula so they're
saying this is something again you might
have to do on a test I'll say okay at
209 or two the correction is zero at
three zero point zero the correction is
minus seventy three so up here you can
see we've got this formula where are we
interpolated between the two to try to
figure out what would the pressure
altitude be if we start with Field
elevation of thirty five sixty three and
the altimeter is two nine or nine or six
which is just a little bit non-standard
we would expect a forty foot difference
if we look at the table and we
interpolate we come up with a thirty six
point five foot difference and we find
out that the the airplane feels as
though it's only at thirty five twenty
six feet above sea level
assuming the temperature matches that
Isis standard alright so density
altitude is a lot more important and
often times it'll be reported on the a
sauce or Aegis so the airport will
actually tell you density altitude is
three thousand feet or two thousand feet
or whatever it is that you get from
correcting the what's usually a
relatively small correction for pressure
altitude compared to the actual altitude
but correcting it for the non standard
temperature I think as I said earlier
you know flying is a lot more popular
New England in the summertime then in
the winter time so it's usually warmer
than standard density altitude has a
huge effect on performance and it's a
nonlinear relationship so you have to
look it up in a table or calculate it
with the e6b we'll see maybe I'll play
around with the e6b or also people can
look at it during breaks I have
the slide rule and the manual right here
I think I will try to get the document
camera going so maybe I can show you
guys some exciting slide rule activities
okay so you can calculate it though
using the e6b like I said using charts
and there's various web and app way of
doing it so the density altitude here's
a chart so again this is the kind of
stuff that's on the written exam you
guys are all pretty good at working with
charts and tables so I'm sure you won't
have any trouble they're giving you
these initial conditions up here on your
left so you look to find where the
pressure altitude is on the chart and it
says to you know add 626 feet which is
interpolating between those two then
you've got this pressure altitude line
of going from here down to here at 5856
and now we've got to correct that for
temperature so here's our temperature of
about 80 degrees 81 degrees and then we
go over to the left and we can read that
I think I told you guys that in the
summertime usually the density altitude
is about 2000 feet higher than the
pressure altitude and sure enough here
it's 80 250 which is about 2,400 feet
higher than the pressure altitude so the
density altitude gave us a little more
than a 2,000 foot
boost for that non-standard temperature
the reason it's so much I guess is it's
not you know 80 degrees at sea level
wouldn't be that high above the standard
temperature but 81 degrees Fahrenheit at
a mile above sea level is is quite a
spectacular temperature given the
compared to the standard atmosphere
let's go back
standard atmosphere yeah so at 5,000
feet it's only supposed to be seven
degrees Celsius and here we said it was
you know about 27 degrees Celsius so
that's ice applause 20 just like I said
if you look a lot of jet performance
charts you have ISO minus 20 ice ax and
ice ax plus 20 ooh
flight computer demo if there's time let
me just what's with that at the end of
all this I'll give you an e6b intro when
are they the same when the temperature
just I think this is an FAA test
question when the temperature
distribution is the same as that of the
standard atmosphere okay
humidity is also another enemy a little
bit more surprisingly the water vapor
molecules actually in the air actually
reduced the instant density of the air
you might think that they would increase
it I don't know maybe there's a chemist
or a physicist in this crowd who can
explain why I'm not exactly sure myself
but it's just something to remember that
contrary if the air feels heavy to you
it feels light to your aircraft engine
and to your wings it's a smaller effect
in temperature but the engine
performance supposedly can be reduced by
about 7% this is not something that we
normally correct for however there is
this nice web calculator that I found
for free on pilot friend calm and you
got to enter the relative humidity of
the air so there is that we have the air
temperature we have the dew point right
so we said it was a third degree
temperature and a 28 degree dew point so
that's a pretty that's a pretty narrow
spread and therefore it's a pretty high
humidity day so they say well it's 78%
humidity and we're correcting that up to
80 107 if we reduce the
can play around with us on your own if
you reduced the dew point to ten degrees
Celsius which is going to be a really
dry you know 30 - 10 split as a nice dry
day out west or you know here
occasionally at Christmas a crisp day
then it's only 77 35 so that the change
in humidity had about a 300 foot effect
on the altitude but the change in
temperature was you know nearly nearly
three thousand feet okay the maximum
convenient way to do this is with apps
so for flight for example will just tell
you the density altitude this was I
think Sunday night at Bedford let's look
at this beautiful I don't know how many
people will come to New England now so
benefits approximately at sea level
about 130 feet above sea level it was
minus 4 degrees and the density altitude
was minus 1400 so we were like flying
you know skimming the surface of the
Dead Sea or something in terms of
performance so the airplane will be
really happy about flying all wintertime
and it will climb better than the book
this most of the numbers in the book
okay
the density altitude is often just kind
of baked into the performance chart so
here is Piper's normally takeoff with no
flaps but if you want to get off the
ground really quickly like taking off
over grass or mud or something you can
put down the flaps and try to have less
time on the ground and not be going so
fast over the ground your ground roll
will be shortened anyway so here you
don't actually ask you to ever calculate
the density altitude they just say okay
it's almost 30 degrees outside and it
looks like we're up here at about 1,500
feet so we'll start here on the
performance chart these people are
virtuous the only way 2175 total so we
come down a little bit and we can go
over here and we find that it's going to
take
is there a wind here 15 knots of
headwind so we come down this graph and
we find that it'll take us 1500 feet to
take off over a 50-foot obstacle
fair enough so anyway we never figured
out what the density altitude was it was
just something that affected where we
started on the chart I guess maybe it's
implicit in here I think it is implicit
right because we're starting up high
maybe somebody who's smarter can figure
this out yeah so sea level at zero yeah
I think we can pull it out of those
how do those graphs but nobody would
because you're what you're really
interested in is the number of how long
you're going to be on the runway all
right
you'll have to slow down if you're in
turbulence so if you plan for some kind
of flight a certain amount of time and
it's going to be very bumpy remember we
talked about maneuvering speed depending
on your weight you'll have to slow down
to avoid bending the aircraft or you
know turbulence is severe enough to bend
then the aircraft is extremely rare
about turbulence it's sufficient to make
you know you and your passengers unhappy
is a lot more common and in both cases
you know you pull way back on the speed
so in the Pilatus for example you'll
pull back to 150 knots from 200 knots in
the Cirrus you know you might pull back
from 130 down to 100 and in a helicopter
you know you'll pull back from 110 knots
to maybe 70 okay
pilot technique so all the book numbers
you know depend on the pilot doing what
the book says so think about you know
clearing an obstacle at the end of the
runway that's depending on the pilot
rotating you know within a couple knots
of the specified rotation speed getting
the gear and the flaps retracted if
there's if they've been deployed or if
the gear are retractable at the
recommended airspeed and just generally
having you know the pitch attitude and
the air speeds where the manufacturer
tested the aircraft and think about it
go or you might say well you know
anybody can do that you're rolling down
the runway at Hanscom field it's a mile
and a half long
you know you're fresh so that
performance is you're probably going to
come pretty close to the book
performance but think about doing a
go-around you've just done a two-hour
flight you were trying to land at the
airport you know somehow either there
was somebody else on the runway or you
know you didn't get the approach just
right so you decided you're gonna go
around and try again at that point you
know you've got to reconfigure the
airplane change the flap configuration
change the gear configuration there's a
couple interesting incidents that have
happened like one of them was
unfortunately not very interesting for
the people involved but there was an
American Airlines flight
they've got disoriented in Columbia in
the clouds and the terrain warning
system said you know terrain terrain
pull up pull up
and so they advanced the thrust levers
you can follow that link and read about
it they advanced the thrust levers and
had maximum power but they neglected to
they had the spoilers deployed for a
descent they didn't retract the spoilers
so the airplane was still was climbing
but not nearly as well as it would have
without the spoilers retracted so that's
an example where you know in a critical
situation or a fatigue situation you may
not I wish I could I wish I could get
this I don't know if I can move this
under the screen I want to show you a
picture of this crazy airplane that I
flew tada
look at that Russian seaplane it's got
too serious engines in there
I don't even see the second engine well
there it is you can see that propeller
over there so sorry there's one
propeller sticking up there's the other
one so it's got too serious engines 200
horsepower each mounted on pods and if
you say like how can the airplane climb
after an engine failure on one little
Cirrus engine when it has I don't know I
think it could seat seven people the
answer is it really can't so I tested
that airplane out because I thought it
was cool and they went flying with an
airline captain and piston twins aren't
really required to demonstrate any kind
of climb performance or jets there are
certain minimums you know on one engine
it has to be able to you know still
climb 750 feet per minute or something
but for these piston twins the FAA says
you know you should know that you're
buying a pig anyway and if you care go
and get yourself a turbine or don't or
don't load everybody in there but anyway
this barrier thing it could not climb on
one engine like we couldn't even
maintain altitude on one engine and it
turned out that we'd forgotten to close
the cowl flaps it had these extra
openings for cooling to provide extra
cooling at high power settings and if
you don't close them there's extra drag
and that extra drag was enough to turn
what should have been you know a hundred
and fifty foot climb rate or something
into a 150 foot sync rate or something
so that's another thing that can affect
performance
okay runway condition this really
affects your planning whether you can
takeoff whether you can land how much
weight you can put in there so for
example if it's dry grass it's you need
a longer runway then if it's paved
alternatively you can take off at a
lower weight if it's wet grass you need
a lot more room to land and you know yet
more room to take off at the airline if
the runway was grooved which almost all
bigger US airports have these groove
runways we didn't make any adjustments
didn't matter how heavy the rain was it
didn't matter how long I've been rating
we just
assume it was going to perform exactly
the same as if it were dry if it's not a
groove Drummle though and water can sit
on the runway it can have a big effect
on performance so here are some numbers
that I pulled I'm type rated in the
Cessna Mustang which is an interesting
little business jet it lands at about
the same speed as a Beechcraft Baron so
it's a great beginner jet anyway so in
conditions where you need 3,000 feet of
runway that's up at pretty high altitude
you're gonna need 40 to 40 Cessna says
if it's wet if water is actually
standing on it I think point 1 inches of
water was even more you'll need yet more
runway if it's snow a little bit more
wet ice it was just off the chart but if
you started at 2,200 feet of dry runway
you would need sixteen thousand six
hundred feet so actually oftentimes when
the surface is contaminated that's one
reason why even fairly small business
jets may need a long runway like at
Logan or at Hanscom field even an
airport like Nashua has 6,000 feet may
not be enough if they're reporting that
there's snow on the runway okay what
about slope so going downhill is
obviously a lot easier than going uphill
and you can see here and also stopping
going uphill it's a lot easier so here
are some numbers from the Cirrus book
that every one degree of slope increases
your takeoff run by 22% at sea level for
example and if you you also get a nine
percent reduction in the landing
distance okay sealing the service
ceiling of the aircraft is a little bit
below the absolute ceiling that's where
the FAA says the plane will climb a
hundred feet per minute or the
manufacturer has demonstrated to the FAA
that the airplane could at least when it
was brand new make 100 feet per minute
and climb rate so that's at 13,500 feet
for a 172 Cessna and I think that's
pretty typical for these normally
aspirated for Cedars somewhere around
there is where it'll stop climbing
the Cirrus there's a limitation in there
that says maximum operating altitude is
17,500 feet I think that's more
regulatory because you can't take the
cirrus up into the flight levels we need
extra equipment to go up you know above
18,000 feet maybe I don't think it's
really practical to get up to 17,500
feet at maximum gross weight in a
standard atmosphere I've gotten into
about 13,000 feet out west in the summer
so that is more like being at 15,000
feet but it was barely climbing okay
range versus endurance so we're gonna
get back into the power and drag curbs
here the max range airspeed is going to
depend on the wind like I said earlier
if you have a hundred knot head wind
then you have to go faster than 100
knots in order to go anywhere if you
want a loiter for some reason this year
at Oshkosh was a nightmare for people
who didn't go IFR they had a lot of
marginal VFR weather so for the first
couple of days when people were arriving
you know there were these short windows
just an hour or two when people could
really get in legally the VFR
homebuilder types so they were just
holding they people were literally
holding for three hours and then finally
had to give up and go and refuel
somewhere but if you're in that
situation you want to set your speed to
whatever the minimum fuel consumption
speed is and it can be quite different
the Robinson r44 manual talks about a
hundred knots for max range
I believe that's assuming a tend not
headwind since usually we're suffering
with the headwind more often than for
the tailwind and you might say how is
that possible how is it possible to have
a headwind unless God hates you how is
it possible to have a headwind more than
half the time if you think about it
Richard you know the answer what is it
in zero minutes how long does it take to
fly you got an airplane that flies
hundred miles an hour how long does it
take to fly round-trip soon fifty nine
Edwin it's exactly 50 knots and fifty
nine tails and on the way back how long
does it take wrong work it out well
that's one aspect you're going to spend
more of your time as Richard as Richard
saying it's gonna take you two hours to
get there in one direction and then it
won't take you zero time to get back so
you're spending more of your time in the
headwind than in the tailwind but
there's something even worse I saw this
the other day in the cirrus there was
about a 70 knot wind that was actually a
little bit it should have been a little
bit of a tailwind it was so it was more
than 90 degrees off my desired track but
if you think about it the airplane is
constantly having to fight its way back
into that wind so it's effectively
taking a longer flight path so even the
wind is directly a beam wind 90 degrees
off there's actually the majority of the
circle of the 360 degree circle of wind
directions the majority of that is
subtracting from your performance and
has at least some headwind component
sound crazy I think about it yeah so if
you're going 100 miles and there's also
this hundred not side wind you're having
to spend quite a bit of your energy
continuing to steer into that side wind
okay here is a power and drag curve for
an RV sex-ay the experimental guys are
in this case more aggressive about
producing charts
so if you actually care about where
you're going you want to be a little bit
up the power required curve you want to
find out where it's tangent to one of
these lines going back to zero and if
all you care about is maximum endurance
you just want to be at the point where
the curve is at its bare minimum because
then you're consuming the least power
and in theory burning the least amount
of fuel does that make sense
all right the terms ground roll these
performance charts in the book that you
get with the airplane they will assume a
static start so that means you're
holding the brakes you slam the power
forward you let off the brakes and
you're gonna get the book numbers
because there's no acceleration time for
the engine and actually that's how Jets
are supposed to take off too but you
probably remember from your commercial
flights that's not really how it happens
the pilots don't hold the brakes you
know spend it takes maybe 10 seconds for
a really heavy jet engine to spool up to
full power they don't just sit there
holding the brakes yeah this is the max
and everything's screaming in the
airplane shaking because it's just
uncomfortable so they usually cheat oh
there aren't really technically they're
not really supposed to do it because you
know at that point your test pilot so
you don't really have any data for a
rolling takeoff but you know it's again
it would be kind of unnerving for
passengers I think if they were sitting
there with the airplane straining
against the brakes okay same deal here
ground roll and the total distance to
clear the 50-foot obstacle this is why I
was telling you about the other day with
the Cirrus hero we wanted to go to I
think about 2,500 feet of runway
actually we had to subtract some now I
think it was 2,700 minus 400 he had
about 2300 feet of runway and he wanted
to go there in the cirrus which takes
2,100 feet another guy actually wanted
to go to there's a private air park in
Falmouth Massachusetts where you can
have a house right next to the runway
and keep the airplane in your garage
and that airports only 2300 feet long
and another East Coast arrow club guy
you know I was handing the airplane over
to him and he has huge friend with him
this guy was like a NFL linebacker so it
was just the two of them but big and he
wanted to fill he wanted also at full
topped off on fuels they're gonna be
writing a gross weight I said where are
you going he said Falcon I said he just
got in his private pilot's certificate
it you know a few months earlier this
guy was not commercial IFR rated like
the other and I said look you know if
you do everything perfect you're gonna
use up 92% of that runway because it's
him didn't buy these obstacles so don't
do it so he did end up going to Hyannis
I think all right landing technique can
actually affect the performance so they
talked about like an average pilot the
book numbers they're predicated on
extremely aggressive braking like right
to the point where you good flat flat
spot the tires so don't count on getting
those book numbers unless you're willing
to be more aggressive than probably you
would want to be and actually I'll tell
you a story about my airline days I did
a visual approach in the LaGuardia and
with jets it's not conventional to try
to do the really greaser landings that
you would do in a little airplane
because you need to get the airplane
down and the spoilers to pop up the jets
are very efficient gliders they don't
have a big prop in front and when you
pull the power back on a piston aircraft
it really slows down dramatically
because the prop has a lot of air
resistance none of that's going for you
with the jet which is more efficient to
begin with so basically the task of an
airline pilot is really to slam it on
and that way the spoilers pop up and
then the brakes start really working
effectively and you turn off the runway
and LaGuardia before you go into the
river so I landed like a Cirrus because
it was my first you know month on the
job and I chewed up you know probably
1,500 feet of runway before the airplane
touched down and I applied fairly gentle
braking and thrust reverse and turned
off after about 5,000 feet of runway and
the captain was like that sucked I'm
going to show you how it's done the next
leg
we went to we did LaGuardia to Charlotte
North Carolina who else did that leg
captain Sully so he dumped his
passengers into a filthy cold river and
they called him a hero I got my
passengers to Charlotte warm and dry and
where was my medal where was my fame
nowhere all right so life is unfair
you've learned that anyway so the
captain takes this one air traffic
control lines us up instead of the
visual approach where you're doing
everything by eye and following another
aircraft and you can't use any of the
fancy automation we were lined up you
know 10 or 15 miles out for a straight
an approach to this angled runway at
Charlotte and all the captain headed it
was on autopilot all I had to do was
tweak the thrust levers for the perfect
airspeed the autopilots flying he
disconnects the autopilot a couple
hundred feet above the ground
now he's hand flying all he has to do
the CRJ doesn't have the 50 seater
doesn't have any leading-edge devices so
it has to be pointed down a bit like a
lawn dart it's not that different from
landing a cirrus it's unconventional for
an airliner the airliners you notice
they usually because of the leading edge
devices even when they're going 120
knots or so they can be kind of nose up
and they still fly pretty well so the
airplane almost can be flown you know
and it can all al and in some cases onto
the runway by itself with just a slight
additional flare at the end the CRJ has
to be kept nose down 145 knots faster
than all but the very biggest jets and
then it has to be you know flared from
minus five to maybe plus five or plus
seven at the end so the captain after
telling me what a bad job I had done he
flared about five feet too high and the
airplane just sailed over 4,500 feet of
runway I think before it finally touched
down and he slammed on the brakes
maximum thrust reverser we barely made
it off and he who made it off at after
7,200 feet of runway so it would have
been I think in the water in LaGuardia
so that's the kind of thing where you
know you can't that's why these these
safety margins are good to build into
your own flying because you know
that the book number said the airplane
would land a lot shorter than that also
in a jet there's really not a good
go-around technique once you're below
fifty feet you're not supposed to try to
add power and go around because it takes
a while to spool the engines up alright
in turbulence you usually will increase
your approach speed which means you're
gonna chew up more runway you're
supposed to add half the gust factor has
a rule of thumb so if the wind is 15
gusting 25 you're gonna speed up your
approach by 5 knots and I got the
numbers here for the Cirrus 75 is kind
of a good overall number and then you'll
beef it up to 80 but that means unless
it really is a headwind when you're
landing
you're gonna chew up a little more
runway than expected okay flaps as Tina
mentioned they enable you to keep your
approach speed low while having a nice
steep approach angle so that's good for
getting over trees and stuff if you're
in an aerobatic airplane or something
else it doesn't have flaps you can
actually slip and kind of go sideways
down towards the runway and get over the
obstacles but it's a lot easier just to
put the flaps down okay the charts are
come in all kinds of variations in the
poh especially for the bigger airplanes
you'll have you know ten charts that
look identical except for a couple
numbers like the exact flap position
whether the anti-icing is on or off the
piper warrior pH is a lot simpler and
that's some of the charts were going to
cover and in addition to some of the you
know anonymous airplane charts of the
FAA gives you with the test so one thing
to remember if you're a renter in
addition to the fact that you know you
want to build in maybe some charter and
airline minimums into your flying is
that all those numbers were were the
brand-new airplane that was perfectly
straight and had a perfect engine okay
so wind components you're going to get
shorter takeoff and landing distances
with a headwind a tailwind actually it
may not be legal to operate a
high-performance aircraft on a runway
with a tailwind of more than a certain
amount I think for the CRJ
it was ten knots we just simply could
not land I would attend not tell and or
more than attend not tell and crosswind
is a little bit different you'll get a
maxed him and straight across one
component in the manual so it'll tell
you a test pilot managed to hold this
airplane straight on the runway with
full flaps or whatever the normal
landing configuration is and there was
enough rudder to you know land for the
fifteen not crosswinds that's max
demonstrated it's not a limitation so
you may and if it is you know it'll say
this is a limitation but max
demonstrated just means a test pilot did
it it'll probably work for you too
if you manipulate the controls in the
same way and beyond that you can't be
sure so one thing that people will do is
they will adjust the flap amount to have
a reduced and reduced use of flaps and a
heavy cross wind that keeps the airspeed
up you will chew up more runway but when
the wheels actually touch the ground the
wheels provide a little bit of
stabilization and help keep you from
getting blown off the runway you're
gonna see tomorrow
dojo from the Brazilian Air Force is
going to tell you about testing the
various airplanes but especially the
Super Tucano
in very heavy crosswinds you know down
there in South America they have some
pretty heavy winds I think they went to
Chile to do that it could be wrong or
maybe it was just right next to the
Andes in Brazil okay crosswinds right so
this here shows you that if you have
a 40 knot wind at a 30-degree angle you
go over here on the chart to the 30
degree line you use this 40 knot ring
and then you can find that it's a 35 not
headwind and it's 1 knot crosswind does
that make sense I will tell you when I
was getting a type rating for the Cessna
Mustang at flight safety there were a
couple Boeing 737 pilots there and they
had no idea how to use this chart and
they they couldn't even give the right
answers like if you said you know your
landing on runway two-seven and the
wind's coming from you know three one
five is that a head tail wonder or head
wind and they couldn't answer that
question either it's a quick you know
all they do is go from towered airports
at Howard Airport the tower tells them
what runway to use they were from the
Philippines so I guess it's not you know
insanely windy there like it would be in
Argentina I once landed in Argentina and
knew sh Y ax on a commercial airline
flight and it was 50 not it was the wind
was I think 35 gusting 50 and the pilots
you know is just I talked to them
afterwards they said it was just a
normal day like they wouldn't even
bother talking about that so anyway
these skills
apparently rust I'm sure those guys you
know had used a chart like that at one
point in their training they did get
their type rating so the good news is
you can get your type rating without
knowing how to use that ok here's one of
the FAA charts this is what they give
you on the test it's a lot easier to use
and the poh here's a problem they're
giving you an example problem let's see
we're at somewhere in Colorado
apparently 56 50 feet we weighed 2900 50
pounds in this airplane that they won't
tell us what it is it's 9 knots of
headwind notice these associated
conditions these are really critical and
again if they give you a choice of
multiple charts that's where the trick
is you know they don't trying to get you
you as the wrong chart that's more on
the ATP exam than on
the private one but ya see here powerful
throttle Cal flaps are open this is some
kind of more complicated more
complicated plane that you got the right
mixture set even before you take off for
high altitude alright so what do we got
here we got temperature of 15 we go up
to the pressure altitude pretty close to
6,000 we come over here we're apparently
writing a gross weight so at least
that's realistic most aircraft take off
you know ready a gross weight for most
flights there's nine knots of wind so
that's going to subtract a little bit
from our arm weigh requirements and here
we can see it's 1,500 feet of ground
roll and a little over what is that 2300
yeah 2,300 to clear the 50-foot obstacle
so these charts are not hard to use and
in the real world maybe in the maybe in
the FAA figure they actually give you
this example so you can see how it's
done and then you know you just draw the
lines in a different place
so you're not trying to trick you here's
a chart for the Pilatus pc-12 there's
also apps to do it which i'll show you a
little bit later similar to that piper
chart we saw earlier where you you
calculate the density altitude without
realizing that you've calculated it yeah
so here you've got pressure altitude and
temperature and you're implicitly
calculating them to the altitude then
you go over to wait look at this one the
pelada skies I think they're having some
fun here they're saying you're taking
off at 7,000 pounds so like you you're
missing a whole 3,000 pounds of people
in bags and you paid all this money for
this airplane and you're barely using it
so I don't think that happens too often
unless you just dropped everybody off at
an airport with no fuel and you're
repositioning anyway so they got the
headwind they got uphill and downhill
all bacon this nice chart you can get
all these good numbers this is why
serious is better either the best-seller
they just say look here's this table
there's a few Corrections that you can
use if you want to up there in the upper
right
for headwind tailwind grass but
basically they make the usual case very
simple of a level runway a paved runway
it's always more conservative to go more
you know you don't have to interpolate
you can just say well it's 25 degrees so
I'll use the 30-degree number okay what
is the rate of climb here we're at a
gross weight of 1670 pounds it's 2,000
feet how do we figure that out this is
one of the FAA example tables and it's
as simple as finding the right row in
the table row and column in the table so
actually I have a look here so they're
saying the mixture has to be lean to get
these numbers the flaps have to be up
you got to be at full throttle okay same
deal max rate of climb I forget if this
is a this might be a Piper chart but you
can see that associated conditions up at
there in the top left that's absolutely
critical you know the gross weight
serious actually a lot of the
performance numbers in the Cirrus for
cruise speed are at a 2600 pounds and
you're flying along at you know 2950
because you took off the 3000 you're
wondering like how come I'm not getting
these numbers but of course you know
they're they're being optimistic about
they're putting their airplane in the
best light by positing some weight that
probably doesn't exist in real life
all right here they give us an example
of 5,000 feet pressure altitude Oh 80 of
16 degrees so I said plus 11 max rate of
climb 374 so I guess yeah 5,000 feet
here's ice ax plus 11 it says 376 with
some kind of an elaborate interpolation
I guess you find that last couple feet
per minute that you subtract
here's cruise charts I think again this
is from the FAA test supplement they're
just giving you a remember I told you it
would be ice and minus 20 that's the
chart on the left the one in the middle
is a standard day and on the right as a
summer day
ISO plus 20 notice that they'll give you
fuel flow and the true airspeed given
various engine speed and manifold
pressure settings this looks like it's
four piston twin
okay landing performance is pretty
similar kind of chart I'm not going to
go through this exactly but you can see
they're giving you the work to example
and you come up with let's see it's
going to be about a thousand a little
over a thousand feet of ground roll and
1700 feet they claim of to clear a
50-foot obstacle here's an FAA question
actually so let's see determine the
total distance required for takeoff to
clear a 50-foot obstacle standard
temperature sea level so actually this
is this is testing you this is pretty
advanced right they're saying it's the
standard temperature at sea level so you
have to know that it's 15 degrees
we only weigh twenty-six twenty-seven
hundred pounds
so we're gonna have to ride down this
curve a little bit and the winds calm so
we're not going to get any boost from
the wind so what do you guys think have
any of you have any of you been able to
kind of see what the most likely number
is by following these somebody says eh
let's see it's a little bit lighter that
kind of makes sense but on the other
hand the winds calm so we didn't get
that reduction from the wind let's see
so if we came down here it's gonna start
from sea level 15 degrees come over here
come down here over a 50-foot obstacle
then we have to go up anybody want to
revise their estimate a we heard a last
time it seems a little short to clear
the 50-foot obstacle I agree with you
that you'd be well off the ground by a
thousand feet all right obviously in the
chicken you know if you have a pencil
and a little more time to do that it's
easier all right let's look at you know
that's kind of the hard way let's look
at the easy way
getting the runway numbers for low
performance aircraft it actually remains
pretty common to just use the Poh people
aren't usually in a situation where they
have to worry about it if you're going
from Hanscom field or Martha's Vineyard
and back you know both airports are big
enough for a Boeing and you're not going
to be carefully calculating these
numbers unless you really don't have
much else to do apps though are
available even for low performance
aircraft and they're very useful if
you're going you know into tighter
airports and you might have to worry
about that the time and fuel stuff is
everywhere on the web and the apps but
the actual runway numbers are a little
bit less common let me show you a couple
things here's Geronimo
so this is they sell these four
different aircraft this is just off
their website and for an sr-22 you can
see you put in they must be European
because they say aircraft mass 33:59 and
you've got your temperature your takeoff
elevation your altimeter runway
conditions I don't know what that plus
5% is maybe they're saying oh I don't
know if that's between is that there's
at half grass and half paved anyway you
can put in everything relevant and it's
going to tell you how much ground roll
and how much takeoff distance so that's
pretty slick it's a lot easier than
relying on the poh the the calculator
for the Pilatus is free that's the good
news
and here same deal you put in your
weight the temperature if there's any
headwind the airport elevation and you
get the numbers all right
we can try to get the dock camera
working for a demo in a minute here but
in the meantime first of all are there
questions and secondly what is this
aircraft and what's it designed for yeah
print the test supplement that's public
it's in our Dropbox and also the FA
makes this chart supplement public so
you can see all the figures that you're
gonna see before the test I think I
think actually when you're done with
your test in ink you can print out all
the questions and we'll show you what
you got right yeah just print out the
chart
yeah print out sure print out the chart
supplement anybody have any brilliant
ideas about this aircraft
it says Greer's on it
[Music]
that's a Burt Rutan design the climate
change denier and this is a super short
filled airplane it's not it actually
doesn't land as short as you might think
I think it might be a four-seater though
so I guess it is pretty darn short for a
four-seater but it has huge flaps and a
lot of wing area and it's got that I
think it has ordinary sea it has
essentially three free surfaces right
it's got kind of a helper wing or a
canard out in front the regular wing and
then an ordinary conventional tail plane
let me see if I can get this dock camera
working all right so let's say we want
to know how much fuel we're going to use
see that fuel pounds there we can where
is that somewhere along here
well actually I happen to know it's got
to be somewhere
we're ten pounds yeah see there's US
gallons right there so we line this up
and you can tell this was designed for
piston folks because their idea of fuel
weight is six pounds per gallon and jet
fuel weighs six point seven but at this
point now we got our handy slide rule so
we know if we load on for example ten
gallons of fuel it's going to be 60
pounds and if we load on you know the
series holds 56 gallons that's gonna
weigh 300 and looks like 345 sorry 335
gallons its 335 pounds
more to the point you can calculate
density altitude so over here for
example you can say the pressure
altitude is let's call it sea level and
it's very hot though it's plus 40
degrees so now you see the density
altitude up there is about 2,000 feet
that makes sense so you've set the
pressure altitude at the bottom or
inside this little window at zero and
then the density altitude gets read out
here after you line it up with the
temperature it's also something that you
can do well just with the basic rate so
let's say you decide that you're going
to be going this is more for performance
planning but let's say you're a Cirrus
and you're going 150 knots if you end up
needing to go let's say 300 nautical
miles it tells you that I'll take you
two hours not too exciting but
the wind side is a little more exciting
I'll bring a pencil tomorrow for the
flight planning talk and we can play
around with wind vectors on there but
anyway fortunately a lot of this stuff
is explained in the book you guys are
free to come up and play around with it
anytime there's temperature conversion
scale here on the bottom and it's a fun
toy teen or anything else
that we should cover here or should we
segue what's the next okay the next one
is weather data you you'll need a break
for that one that's how you find out all
this stuff let me go back to the PC who
else has questions
[Music]
/ and looking at pH craft like which one
what you want to do with the FAA exam
ones land landing performance or this
one from the actual test this one okay
so I don't think they ever give it
worked out for you let me switch to the
laser pointer mode okay so what did they
tell us they told us it was standard in
sea level that's the one part of the
standard atmosphere that people I think
are expected to remember it at sea level
it should be 15 degrees Celsius so we
come down here we say it's 15 degrees
out we're gonna hit the sea level
pressure altitude we're gonna slide over
this way just like in the example and
then we're gonna slide down following
this curve to 2,700 pounds and we're
gonna go over here and we're gonna say
look there's no wind the winds calm so
we'll keep going over here and we find
that we need about a little less than a
thousand feet maybe 800 feet for a
ground roll but to clear the 50-foot
obstacle look at the bottom there we
need to go up following one of these
lines and that's how we get to the 1,400
number did that help you still look a
little bit skeptical
remember remember we would be doing this
with a virtual pencil none of these
lines these lines are just for reference
telling you kind of what slope to follow
your with your pencil so it's not like
the it's not like these are the only
available points so it's not like it's
going to be either this for the answer
this for the answer or this for your
answer even in their work example you
can see their red line for the answer is
just parallel to that gray line it's not
they're not picking one of the gray
lines so they're their guidelines for
you know how you should move your pencil
in each phase I hope this motivates you
to buy that Jai ronimal app I certainly
wouldn't motivate me to do it if you
want to look at it on a real book I'll
pass around again this is my this is my
Poh for Cessna 172 so this might be the
type of plane that you're using as your
training aircraft and I have a couple
pages that are marked with a piece of
paper so one talks about how you
calculate the take-off distance and one
is weight and balance will actually have
a whole section dedicated to weight and
balance but just to give you a sense of
you know how you can follow with your
pencil and you'll actually see some
pencil markings of my own fairly fairly
close to the limits here of our center
of gravity moment envelope here but
still within the box so just to give you
an idea of how you can do that with a
real paper and pencil
[Music]
yeah the question is you know we don't
have any kind of readout in the aircraft
for density altitude so is that why
we're always calculating with our handy
6 B or listening to the a sauce or
whatever so yeah yeah basically your
instruments in the aircraft can tell you
the temperature outside air temperature
maybe not quite as accurate as the one
from the airport if you're on the ground
and they can also show you if you set
your altimeter two to nine and nine or
two you can see the pressure altitude
but the relationship between the two is
not simple and there's nothing on board
the aircraft conventionally that will
calculate it for you and I think that's
quite true I think a lot of modern GPS
boxes will do that calculation for you
but you have to type in all the numbers
they don't usually just grab it they
will give you things like true airspeed
like they'll definitely calculate that
so you know if you're indicating 150 but
you're up really high they'll tell you
well now you're going 200 knots in true
airspeed and then they'll give you your
ground speed too and they'll even show
you a little wind vector any other
questions
okay great so we'll just take a
ten-minute break and start up again at
2:15 with weather data and that's the
one you guys seem to keep asking about
so we'll talk about also towards the end
of that talk how you build build your
own ats-v receiver
you